Eh, it's good,
but Dana Carvey did it first.
"Imagine every morning you wake up,
you can't remember who you are."
"Your name is M.L. Poug."
"Sh*t."
_
So if you're a Nolan fanboy,
enjoy the best movie ever made
until The Dark Knight.
Which, I guess was the best movie
ever made until Inception.
Which, according to you all, was the best movie
ever made until The Dark Knight Rises.
Look, he's proved himself
as a great filmmaker,
but you fanboys rate Dark Knight Rises
over Citizen F*cking Kane?
Dark Knight Rises isn't even
the Citizen Kane of Batman movies!
"Something doesn't feel right.
I think someone's f***ing with me."
Thrill as Lenny attempts to keep his world in order
in a pre-smartphone era.
"(phone ring)"
"Who is this?"
As he utilizes Polaroids,
pen and paper,
"Trust me.
I need to write this down."
and of course, his tattoos.
They're one part case file,
"Fact 6: Car license SG137IU."
one part to-do list,
and one part lyrics
from a new metal song.
♫ Memory is treachery! ♫
Hmm, I wonder which tatt reminds him
to keep frosting his hair every few weeks.
"Yeah, OK. One's fine."
Prepared to be shocked
by revelations like...
This guy isn't who he says is.
And he's actually manipulating Leonard.
"Don't believe his lies."
This girl isn't who she says she is.
And is actually manipulating Leonard.
"I can say whatever the f*ck I want
and you won't remember."
And shockingly,
this guy isn't who he says he is.
And is actually...
Manipulating...
Leonard.
"F*ck."
"Do I lie to myself to be happy?
Yes, I will."
GENIUS!
Meet Leonard,
a single-mindedly obsessed white guy
with slicked back hair,
A.K.A., your typical
Christopher Nolan protagonist.
He's a short-term amnesiac
who can't remember anything after his injury.
"Somebody hit me from behind.
I remember.
It's about the last thing
that I do remember."
Except for the details of his conditions
he devloped after his injury.
Hmm...
"One last thing,
I have this condition."
"Condition?"
"I guess I've already told you
about my condition."
"My condition."
"Because of my condition."
"I have this condit-"
"Yeah, I know all about your
f*cking condition, Leonard!"
He won't rest until he gets revenge
for the death of his wife,
"(gun reload)"
even though it seems like they didn't have
the best relationship to begin with.
"How could you read that again?"
"Don't be a prick.
I'm not reading it to annoy you,
I enjoy it."
"Ouch."
She's just not that into you, bro.
Return to an era when all the best movies
lied to you until the very end.
And experience a twisting story,
told in reverse where you already know
what happens.
But keeps you guessing
as to why.
"What the f*ck you talking about??"
"I don't know."
Because if you put it
in chronological order,
it just a dude who makes
a really long phone call,
describing what's wrong
with him,
then tricks himself into
shooting someone.
"No!"
"(gunshot)"
Brilliant!
From the Michael Bay for people
who've read a book in their life.
Comes the film that kickstarted
the world's Christopher Nolan obsession,
and made people mildly aware
of his brother.
"You are the director's brother."
"This is not the first time
you worked together, correct?"
"Nah, this should be the fifth time
we worked together."
I am so confused.
To see the trailer front-way,
click above to watch our
Honest Trailer Commentary for Memento.
_